I am personally disgusted by the
senseless attacks and murders of good
people by bad people with evil intent
[Music]
the only thing that stops a bad guy with
a gun is a good guy with a gun if you're
a person who is legally licensed to
carry a firearm now is the time more
than ever to realize that you and you
alone may very well be the first line of
defense for you your family and others
around you in a terrorist or active
shooter based scenario
[Music]
here in America it's way too easy for
dangerous people to get their hands on a
gun for example right now people on the
no-fly list can walk into a store and
buy a gun
that's insane
you